Met has developed llama which is a 65
billion parameter model
uh there's a lot of interesting
questions they can ask here one of which
has to do with open source but first can
you tell the story of developing of this
model and uh making the complicated
decision of how to release it yeah sure
I think you're right first of all that
in the last year there have been a bunch
of advances on scaling up these large
Transformer models so there's the
language equivalent of it with large
language models uh the sort of the image
generation equivalent with these large
diffusion models
um there's a lot of fundamental research
that's gone into this and
meta has taken the approach
of being quite open and academic in in
our development
um of AI part of this is we want to have
the best people in the world researching
this and
um and a lot of the best people want to
know that they're going to be able to
share their work so that's part of the
deal that we that we have is that you
know we can get you know if if you're
one of the top AI researchers in the
world you can come here you can get
access to kind of industry scale
um infrastructure and and and part of
our ethos is that we we want to share
what's what's invented
um broadly we do that with a lot of the
the different AI tools that we create
and llama is the language model that
that our research team made and
you know we we did in a limited
um a limited open source release for it
right where which was intended for
researchers to be able to use it
um
but you know the responsibility and
getting safety right on these is um is
very important so we didn't think that
for the first one there were a bunch of
questions around whether we should be
releasing this commercially so we kind
of punched it on that for for V1 of of
llama and and just released it from
research now obviously by releasing it
for research
um you know it's out there but but
companies know that that they're that
they're not supposed to kind of put it
into commercial releases and um you know
we're working on the follow-up models
for this and and thinking through how
um what what the the how exactly this
should work for for follow-on now that
we've had time to to work on a lot more
of the the safety and
um and the pieces around that but but
overall I mean this is
I just kind of think that
that it would be good
if
there were a lot of different folks who
had the ability to build state of the
art technology here you know it's in not
just a small number of of big companies
we're to train one of these AI models
the state of the art models is
um you know just takes you know hundreds
of millions of dollars of infrastructure
right so there are not that many
organizations in the world
um that can do that at the biggest scale
today and no it gets it gets more
efficient every day so
um so I I do think that that will be
available to more Focus over time but
but I just think like there's there's
all this Innovation out there that
people can create and um
and and I I just think that will will
also learn a lot by by seeing what the
whole community of students and
um and hackers and startups and
different folks
um build with this and that's kind of
that's kind of been how we've approached
this and it's also we've done a lot of
our infrastructure and we took our whole
data center design and our server design
and we we built this open compute
project where we just made that public
and
um part of the theory was like all right
if we make it set more people can use
this server design then um then that'll
enable more Innovation it'll also make
the server design more efficient and
that'll that'll make our business more
efficient too so that's worked and we've
we've just done this with a lot of our
our infrastructure
so for people don't know you did the
limited release I think in February of
La of this year of llama
and it got quote unquote leaked
meaning like it's uh
escaped
the uh the the limited release aspect
but it was
you know that something you probably
anticipated given that it's just
released the reasons we shared it with
the researchers right so it's just
trying to make sure that there's like a
slow release yeah uh but from there I
just would love to get your comment on
what happened next which is like this is
a very vibrant open source community
that just builds stuff on top of it
there's uh llama CPP that basically
stuff that makes it more efficient to
run on smaller computers uh there's
combining with uh reinforcement learning
with human feedback so some of the
different interesting fine-tuning
mechanisms there's then also like
fine-tuning and a GPT three generations
there's a lot of uh GPT for all alpaca
uh colossal AI all these kinds of models
just kind of spring up like
run on top of wood yeah like what do you
think about that no I think it's been
really neat to see I mean there's been
folks who are getting it to run on local
devices right so if you're an individual
who just you know wants to experiment
you know with this at home
you probably don't have a large budget
to get access to like a large amount of
cloud compute so getting it to run on
your local laptop
um you know is is uh is pretty good
right and pretty relevant
um and then there are things like yeah
llama CPP
um re-implemented it more efficiently so
you know now even when we run our own
versions of it we can do it on way less
compute and it's just way more efficient
save a lot of money
um for everyone who uses this so that
that is is good
um
I do think it's worth calling out that
because this was a relatively early
release
um
llama isn't quite as on the frontier as
for example the biggest open AI models
or the biggest Google models right when
you mentioned that the largest llama
model that we released had 65 billion
parameters and when no one knows you
know I guess outside of open AI exactly
what the specs are for um for for gpt4
but but I I think the you know my
understanding is it's like 10 times
bigger and I think Google's Palm model
is is also I think has about 10 times as
many parameters now the Llama models are
very efficient so they perform well for
for something that's around 65 billion
parameters so for me that was also part
of this because there's this whole
debate around you know is it good for
everyone in the world to have access to
um to the most Frontier AI models and I
I think as the AI models start
approaching something that's like a
super human intelligence sense like that
that's a bigger question that we'll have
to Grapple with but right now I mean
these are still you know very basic
tools they're um you know they're
they're powerful in the sense that you
know a lot of Open Source software like
databases or web servers can enable a
lot of pretty important things
um but
I don't think anyone looks at the the
you know the current generation of llama
and thinks it's um you know anywhere
near a super intelligence so I think
that a bunch of those questions around
like is it is it good to to kind of get
out there I think at this stage surely
you you want more researchers working on
it for all the reasons that
um that open source software has a lot
of advantages and we talked about
efficiency before but another one is
just open source software tends to be
more secure because you have more people
looking at it openly and scrutinizing it
um and finding holes in it
um and that makes it more safe so I
think at this point it's more
I think it's generally agreed upon that
open source software is generally more
secure and safer
um than things that are kind of
developed in a silo where people try to
get through security through obscurity
so I think that for the scale of of what
we're seeing now with AI
I think we're more likely to get to you
know good alignment and good
um understanding of of kind of what
needs to do to make this work well by
having it be open source and and that's
something that I think is is quite good
to have out there and and happening
publicly at this point